hello emily and twenty for you and
my from belgium
and this comanche s by request for your
teenage apricot of mental suffering and
when i see this document 3m
iphone management and but
[Music]
de white or maybe a complex moro
principle er  is it oh so basically me
never
[Music]
howie mandel life has become more than
most challenging a controversial
issues where to hang
because comes the doctors is detail
belgium as the most lip gloss in the
world
this is emily story
[Music]
from the your site
choose a physical body via men with
the load of family and frames
it freelancers and malia sewage sludge for
but she finds a life and double
a and
off-road ist
it often fell right away destiny beautiful
and green donc il y and a
shire not five
letters  can i choose a lot of injection of
riel and
pointers and
i made that video two years ago call
this moment when i started to say to
people other
than my wish actually was too strong
for me making that video was a bit
more accessible than against
supervision  go tell it
come out with a
death wish
go put that your photo in die and the cross
highcamp picture myself and colors
what go to position
continue
though he owns
omg there
moments her so fragile she is
hard to see design
like a day compare to now then  was
i still like this so we can express her roof in my
death wish how the ring
emily's pin necklace psychological
treatments and she was 12 ja's hour
after a series of suicide attempts to
was i a little too we psychiatric
seems orphan bald
china lift between de  place 0 comments in
bridge
so that moment is a flower ar service
anyway no supplies to 10 times the
limburger
so van
and die
so armi create it so
wednesday you depend on myself
what the intestines and
think it did for five icon we protein
luis know  because it
then give me a no-fly chicken nice your
seat
in 2015 have a nice look hunger
doctor assist details in belgium
why nikes and so and turkey is in bal
people suffering now also from me
physical illness
tribus end we people suffering
psychiatric disorders
the most extreme and controversial phone
fascist maybe
belgium at won something you can race
with his laziness
strict criteria on a girl who grows up for
doctor assistant at isala
emily's kees als ik essence of
medical professionals and ultimately be
signed up guys three doctors
uniform is a psychiatrist  that the does
not deliver tape
i hope you now
put yourself questions you want
discussed maybe
for myself the last few weeks
the destructiveness is
serious again enough
emily examples of replication gardens
live you guys 2 years ago
think we most or  not to be
actually all people with a
request for euthanasia on the basis of psychological
suffering have a long story of
psychological suffering,
so that is completely different from
someone who causes acute depression,
for example, as a result of a
red card that is the correct assessment of the
doctors and the  three doctors who engage with the
patient because within
psychiatry the possibilities are
endless
medication combination of medication with
outpatient residential therapies
we can continue but it must be fair
opportunities that the people really know
can offer perspective
and with some people we have that
way we don't have that and in some
cancers situations
that's also the case with psych divorced sometimes
we don't have anything to offer anymore
[Music]
emily's parties lifelong bartlett
extreme depression and complicate
psychiatric disorder
i think it started very young  i
think the three years or like
i walked to school holding my
grandpa's hand and i thought we are learning to walk
i don't want to be here
maasbree
i think there are different reasons
but sometimes we are right for
example cancer because we are
all good  know
cancer you can capture on photo
and you can see that on an x-ray or
a scan and you see the enemy
with psychological suffering we have nothing that
we can objectify
capture
yes I think the fact that we
cannot
objectively capture it in image  brings that
that is actually the hardest of
all
it's now in the site at download free
doctors
it emily's application for the sixteenth
century and feico
have truth and family and friends come the
trams perfect dualsim icon
spring washers possible place where complain
behind emily's dove hema this is  still mouth
and face to peer in so much
as the men handicap
and start the processes out try to
motivate
contact we dat there zeitguide rick ross
pay them all the diamond part of cz mama
please i stop the new libya a lot of
hassle is
shared work and  helper is he leg
for that
I'm tired of thing is not you we put
column we this will involve your work but
kill him and
he want to be for that house wanted them
all toby
and men
after the magical interventions ink
in which private and great condition
sauces students  new species she keeps herself
it always feels like there's a
monster behind my ribcage that
won't get out and
with the cut having to watch it a
bit days and he drank a have than
more the feeling of look i can
hit it thump  map a man that's
opto knees by drying faithfully because
flares almost a puddle of my tears
because you saw I stand straight don't do it
again by
then the [ __ ] we must become and I
take that out of black to
stand up again every time and
every time
to continue again team of the hair knows
that an hour later five minutes later it does
n't matter
is slow and therefore very the same
ritual we go and that's what makes it so
unbearable because you can
keep getting up because of it but  every
time put each other's language rest well on 8 loses your
feeling
[Music]
emily's we save the news she's been
waiting for
the time spin site
she's measurement with her doctors this is
karsten practica watching is or watching a thing
live
go now  to the life of
fantastic
in belgium
ashens weight and the life's you can
drink sweet works or seven rather
injection of adapter and sometime on this
for the injections
on the day of the performance could work
and will treat people present
have you told that  the grid of
importance and
first came to speak again
determined not yet a nature as well as
with your girlfriends now normal just stand there
asking you very explicitly
moving again really
come to a place can you be so no
that is important
that was  even if [ __ ]
then the kia is
so we are then soon
but you can go far until the last minute
sauce fear container you can do
even more
yes very important I think in that
you know that if you solve
no they that there  you don't believe truth in
rank pancras that i must very fine because
such we go an aspect and the first
spray i know brings you
sleep again like a co-op
of that moment who take note of that
moment is gone before you
because you know  nothing and then
other stuff
that bends it through temptation
that whole procedure of those syringes that
you are the 5
and the death that passes within the row
of team with a u yes
emily's case is reek nights at
nationality and story of belgians
ssd die  logic
sam medical professional support and
right there basically what the muscles
irish of mental suffering
you had to
establish
in an
in [ __ ] is that the a mental illness is
that herbal had to for the mental
illnesses it is still stable stages
and courouble order to  sharing the coast
is an itch a fate or patient
current good better you know
who homies of black black black
death britt post
with had to be office home living
that yoda shows conditions which a
widget is morris
that the so the mercury lead that this this
could be  wood or something
you have to talk to those people yourself if
you don't speak to them anymore then you
cannot understand where then lead set
and why it
is or becomes unbearable
what is it very difficult
collision th process over and over again her
illness condition is so serious that  so it
turns out that it is not viable
by that I mean that it
leads to a life that
is not quality enough for emily
this
[Music]
with the dt&v of this no see you there 2
weeks away emily's meeting with her best
frans francken and lisse de  discography
logo
what do you think of coffee
emily's doctor milling ficus eeej few
words and
[Music]
merci
just look about couples our
friendship
has signs and we could have each other
he
was important to me so that
benefits feels good and can say from that
what that violence are like a
think that is important
yes i feel that in the couple that has passed
in the period that has passed or that
there has not been a moment you say of i
stop it
i want to damn it available has
been just a moment that you  really
preferred a portable life to than
dying if so there is a real doubt
think the biggest doubt put it and
moment of saying goodbye
yes
and sometimes French life hoping
you might still change your mind
of the first one 100 pepper in  belgium to
apply for the white and the long of the
crown segments suffering for the eyes
were accepted
and lavender reception cords that site
game also on the animates you
emily's prosedia is just for day ow
[ __ ] necklace european jews
who
flew goblet of stones from to  me and
on the first day we
met where we go for a walk and then we
came across these stones and we
call them the morlocks
because they are precise lunar craters and I
always saved those until now
so if I had more gang now is  already book
to francoeur
as a reminder of our first
meeting
and the television
that goes and my mom because my mom
still has such an old wide ali kiss
onno the television bak
[Music]
we have a channel really important
[ __ ] i have one  very often about after the hard
and i'm on say don't believe so i do
n't believe a certain thing
but i think it's mainly ho
removing myself
find peace in you can frighten yourself or
catch a yes but then we can
just as good and idea
as we are there brings hours of rest
[Music] [
Music]
the sweet girl it's in the nike
yes it's in your mother crotch
if you don't see then I had after
all these years  still seen it go horrific
and lonely and painful way and has
had to make it down to me good
[Music]
I'm sure had committed suicide
emily spanish charge they building is
your theresia shield fiverr clock in
parliament
for every
lisa
she  came in and they asked me
what are you going to do after the tour
I couldn't answer yet
a doctor gag then came
was a short conversation
and rationally I said I ca
n't do it
because the last two weeks before the
famous Thursday that it  would happen
they were relatively bearable there were
no crises
and for me it was very unclear that
came is therefore the return to b was and
because we can say goodbye where that
made it okay
or has something changed after all is there
something
inside me after all  crept in here
made things a bit more bearable
with the fact that people are allowed
to die or get help
with the rods
brings relative peace to some people
the reassurance that there is an emergency brake
that they can decide when the
really getting too much
helps them to move on
so i've tried to
think about my truth as little as possible and the truth is still to
me you'd rather not be so i'm
kinda firming my heart for the
future
[Music]
a
the
[Music]
[Applause]